hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
the Far Cry series is a compelling
globe-trotting adventure with some of
the most memorable villains in gaming
history with far cry 5 set for release
in early 2018 now is the right time to
look at what kind of shenanigans we'll
be getting into in Hope County
so here's six great things we can't wait
to see in Far Cry 5 let's start right
there
hop County is a fictional County in the
very real US state of Montana the Rocky
Mountains the Great Plains the vast
wilderness are all here in detail and
scattered throughout this open world are
small towns in need of some assistance
will be playing the law and order in
this game our character will be donning
a sheriff's deputy badge and taking on
the doomsday cult who are more than
happy to gun down anyone who doesn't
agree with their vision of an impending
apocalypse these guys are so into their
beliefs they'll kindly baptize anyone
who requires a little spiritual
cleansing far cry 5 will let you make
friends and have an AI partner by your
side the one that everyone is naturally
drawn to is of the four-legged variety
meet boomer the world's most loyal dog
as well as looking like the cutest
little quadrupeds companion ever he
actually has a skill set which gives you
the edge in battle
boomers sense of smell can tag enemies
at range and he can be instructed to
take down Falls too if you decide to
ignore him then he'll act for himself
and still contribute to the fight he can
even disarm cultists and bring the guns
back to you who's a clever little shoot
if you're not a dog person what about
having a human being by your side meet
grace
grace Armstrong is a sniper who can be
instructed to set up a bird's nest
giving her a greater vantage point we'll
let grace obliterate the opposition from
so far away they won't have a clue relay
information to her over comms and she'll
take out or leave alive whoever you
desire I like grace she's my kind of
girl
if militarized personnel aren't your
thing then meet family man and crop
duster Nick Wray he's just trying to
keep his family out of cultist trouble
and uses his aviation skills to
carpet-bomb the mob I don't think he's
really thought this through bombing his
own town in order to save him
but hey everyone's a critic just sit
back and enjoy the fireworks
[Music]
as I mentioned right at the start the
over-the-top villains of far cry make
each game unmissable the outlandish
hairstyles and clothing the witty and
thoughtful wordplay did I ever tell you
the definition of insanity and even the
demonic tendencies make these guys
somehow captivating far cry 5 head
honcho is the leader of the cult which
means it's probably right in thinking
he's pretty good at putting words
together to me his design resembles CM
Punk who was an absolute legend with a
mic in hand and dropped the occasional
pipe bomb to wouldn't it be brilliant if
Punk voiced the far cry 5 villain anyway
I'm getting carried away that
speculation and we're here for facts the
way the character has been depicted
resembles the Last Supper and as we've
already seen a false baptism or two then
it's probably right to expect a bit of
religious groundwork to be in the game
which explains the controversies around
far cry 5 and finally if you think far
cry 5 is all about violence and murder
and killing then you are mistaken in an
open world gun fest time to rest and
recuperate our vital so why not ignore
the crazed enemies and relax with a spot
of fishing there's not much more I can
say here I have no idea how to fish but
rest assured I'll be wading in and
catching one of those hundred mile per
hour fish you know a motor Pike oh sorry
terrible terrible speaking of things to
do outside of combat how about a spot of
Agriculture ever wanted to be a farmer
and saw the fields then jump on a
tractor and Who am I kidding use it as a
tool of destruction and death against
those cultists so there you go that was
six great things we can't wait to see in
Far Cry 5 have I missed anything what
are you looking forward to we'll Far Cry
5b on your list of games to play in 2018
or will you'll be giving this franchise
a rest for a while I'd love to know what
you think in the comments below I'm Adam
from PlayStation granade it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]